pacquiao finally arrives at the
designated place after melody verifies
her kora pika gives two conditions for
both pakanota and chrollo
the first rule for crawlable is that he
is forbidden to use men and the second
is that he may not contact any member of
the phantom troop before placing the
second condition he searches his mind
hard for an alternative but fails to
find one he then claims that his top
priority is to get gon and killua back
to make certain that he adheres to those
conditions he uses his judgment chain on
him
after pacquiao nevada accepts the
conditions koropika puts the chain on
crollo it then gives paco notice
conditions the first is that she must
release gon and killua unharmed before
midnight and without any tricks
second she may not speak a single word
about him she accepts it and koropika
puts the chain on her karapika tells her
to bring back gon and killua to exchange
hostages pakinota agrees and she heads
back to their hideout
at the true tie down finks insists
pakanova to tell him the chain user's
location and that he won't let her leave
before telling him however pakonella
refuses and says that she will take the
kids alone making thinks angry machi
tells her to leave and that she and
cortopi will stop them faten implies
that pakinota manchi and cortopi are
probably under the chain user's control
franklin tells finks to let pakinota go
pakinoda can take the kids to the chain
user but if the boss does not return
then they could kill the controlled
members and start rebuilding the spider
this proposal is quickly agreed upon by
machi although she claims that she is
not being controlled and that killing
her won't be easy
karapika watches as pakinoda and the
boys go back to his place until he
suddenly sees hisoka he phones korapika
and asks to allow him to go inside the
airship along the hostages he claims
that his target is the boss and that he
wants to fight him as the airships land
both parties meet after verifying that
gon and killua are not being manipulated
they begin the exchange
kurapika and the others leave
immediately after that however the
spiders are still there hisoka
challenges crawler to a duel but crawler
says that he is not worth fighting since
he cannot use his men for now this
shocks hisoka and he leaves immediately
on the airship hisoka texts illumi that
he may slip out when it please him he
also informs pakinomena of his true
fortune hisoka would meet with a boss on
tuesday and by the time hisoka left the
phantom troops number would be cut in
half back at the truth's hideout the
remaining members questioned pakimoto's
return without the boss
instead of answering pakinebe charges
her gun and points it at them she then
shoots her maximum six memory bombs
bullets towards fighting finks machi
nobunanda shelnark and franklin with her
memories and feelings in it right now
for that kurapika's judgment chain kills
her instantly while she hopes that she
is the last of the phantom troop to die
on the next day gon and killua are seen
discussing about their plan on getting
the greed island game
while they are entering the hall where
the auction is held they may thinks and
frighten much to the latter's surprise
the boys quickly run from the hall but
are stopped by finks and frighten
immediately
they explain that they are not going to
kill them and that they just came to
enjoy the auction
gone asks about pakinota to which finks
replies that she's dead he then tells
them that she wanted to say thank you to
them and then he leaves with frighten
corapica finally awakes after two whole
days and learns about what happened
after he passed out
at the auction when greed island is
introduced people start bidding but a
man named batara wins the bid by beating
the other bidders including maluki right
after the auction gon and killua
approached batara and volunteered to
play greed island as batarae's hiring
professional hunters to play it battery
declines their offer for a certain
matter but he begins having an interest
when gohan and killua mention the memory
card and the ring they have from jing
badara asks says guerra to examine the
ren level of the two which they
completely failed because their nen
isn't enough to survive the game
says guerra is already an experienced
player of greed island and knows the
dangers of playing
while the two exits finks and fighting
steal a copy of greed island and bring
it to their hideout where they both
enter the game
meanwhile gom and killua plan to
strengthen their nen and start creating
their net abilities
kiluaz starts his training while gohan
is still clueless about what he will do
gon calls wing and asks him about
special abilities wing tells him that
enhancers don't need to have special
abilities for they are the most balanced
in both offense and defense
mastering ren and ten is enough to be
called special abilities in themselves
gone starts his training and although at
first he struggles he realizes all the
training and fighting he did in the past
has accumulated in making him stronger
when using jio he is able to see his nan
and condense it to form a physical mass
of power on his fist
however the nan explodes knocking him
down
gohan becomes excited nonetheless about
the thought of his new ability meanwhile
kalua has increased his electrical power
which started as a spark into a very
powerful technique
korapika and melody leave york new city
to continue their job with the nostrada
family lyorio meets with gohan and kilua
telling them about corapica leaving much
to gohan's disappointment for not saying
goodbye the oreo gives go in his past
book and tells him that zeppel has
recovered his hundred million so he can
buy his hunter license back
meanwhile in the auctions building
batara is seen winning the last greed
island for 60 billion
he has successfully won all seven copies
of the game
however his first copy as announced in
the news was stolen
the following day gone and kahlua attend
a screening for those who want to be
greed island players
in the room where the test takes place
says guerra is inside and ready to judge
kiluah asks to show his hatsu instead of
ren which is agreed by the hunter he
sees killuas nen transforms into
electricity and he is amazed that kalua
learned this in just four days
with that killua has successfully passed
the test he then proceeds to a waiting
room where people who have passed stand
by
suddenly he hears a loud noise from the
previous room
says guerra looks at a giant hole in the
wall caused by gon and is scared of the
two
after the test gone killua and lee oreo
are celebrating at a restaurant leorio
departs for an exam to become a doctor
gome and killua bid farewell and say
that when they meet again he will be a
real doctor
at five o'clock pm the boys go by train
to a mansion where all the greed island
games have been set up to play
after they hear an explanation about the
game they decide the order of who goes
into the game first by a rock paper
scissors match
gome is the first to enter while kilua
ends up being the 17th gome puts on his
ring and claims that he wants to use his
own card
entering the game ita welcomes him and
explains some rules
she also explains that having a ring can
give him two spells gain and book when
gone uses the book spell a book appears
before him
she explains that inside the book there
are 100 restricted card slots and that
to clear the game he must collect them
all
after the explanation gone is allowed to
proceed when he takes a step towards the
entrance of the game ida shows gon a
message from jing through his ring in
his message he explains that greed
island was made by him and his friends
he says if gon is playing in hopes of
searching for any clues of his
whereabouts he's out of luck and that he
only wants to show off the game he has
made he then tells goan have fun playing
it as the message ends gone enters the
greed island field
gone enters the game first and waits for
kalua to join him before proceeding any
further
after waiting for some time his best
friend finally comes and they begin
walking on a green field they both sense
that they are being watched but they
don't know why
meanwhile at the truth's hideout shaolin
ark invites shuzuku and kortopi to play
greed island along with him since there
is nothing for them to do once they get
home to which they immediately agree
back at the game gon and kilua continue
on the field until they walk upon ento
kiba which is known as the city of
prizes once they enter the city they
find a big board that has the anto kiba
monthly tournament schedule written on
it they decided to participate in the
tournament and aim to win all kinds of
prizes gone and killua are in the
championship final round of rock paper
scissors competition by picking rock
over scissors kalua wins his prize being
the sword of truth
in kilauea's hand it immediately becomes
the number 83 card and he puts it in its
respective restricted slot in his book
they worry about someone taking it and
not having any defensive spells when a
nervous player tells them to hand it
over they say no causing the man to use
book and the boys do too he knows
they're new and is about to use the
thief card but before he can gon
snatches it away gone gives back the
card and kilua thanks the man for
letting them know his spell can't be
used until it's said aloud not a moment
later the boys are nearly surrounded by
other greed island players they include
castle asta lin and others stating only
fools participate in tournaments since
they can be stolen right after
defeated gone sits upset totally
outmatched
kiluah says they should go to masadora
city to buy spell cards still being
shattered by biscuit
meanwhile puja abengan jispa and others
meet with nyx and his team to form a
party to defeat the game
they want them to collect spell cards
especially fortress since it's the
strongest defensive card they'll need it
to protect the angel's breath card the
rarest in the game
to get this card they need to trade all
40 spell cards which they have but since
that would leave them with none the knee
fortress for insurance by selling their
gal gada cards gon and killua have
enough money to buy a map when biscuit
finally approaches she asks to join but
kilua says it'll just be a nuisance
making biscuit enraged in her mind
at the same time shalon arc shizuku and
cortupi look on their map xiaomi arc has
discovered npcs that courtope's copying
power doesn't work properly on the cards
and shizuku's vacuum cleaner works but
not on some items his conclusion is
since nen works somewhat they're not in
a virtual world but still a part of the
real world this is from the fact that
the body enters the game and it would be
too difficult to enter the soul greed
island merely warps the players to a
part of the world and the game utilizes
people with men abilities to do so
because the game takes place in the real
world shalnar believes they can take
items out of the game without having to
clear it he wants the eye of god card to
learn more about rarer ones finks and
fighting are also busy killing players
and stealing their spell cards gone and
killua run through a forest with
biscuits still on their tail
at night killua is impressed she's
keeping up while she's impressed with
their strength suddenly ninjas come from
behind trees in front of the three
instead of attacking they bow to the
boy's feet asking for help and coughing
in a sickly manner
in their village a very sick boy lies in
bed as one of them explains how a
disease is spreading
the village elder says the medicine they
have is not enough
and there have been many deaths they
need money for new medicine and right
away going figures this is a game event
the villagers just so happen to know the
exact amount of money the two have left
which would make them broke but biscuit
volunteers to pay
kiluah tells her to be quiet much to her
displeasure and gohan agrees to help the
villagers begin to cry with gratitude
and all very awkward they even take the
shirts off gone and kill who has backs
for the sick boy giving nothing in
return
they're not worried since once they
fight monsters they can sell those cards
to gain more money they run into an
armored monster which is scarier looking
than others biscuit finally helps
telling them to use geo revealing men
inside the armor but coming from another
location gone follows the nen and finds
a little rap monster it turns into a
card as soon as gome startles it making
the armor fall apart biscuit asks why
they didn't use geo earlier and points
her finger to the sky
she orders them to use gyo revealing a
one made of men
kiliwal wonders why she's suddenly
ordering them around and points her
finger gone screams out five which is
correct and biscuit orders kiluah to do
200 push-ups he asks why he should and
she tells them her name and that she has
40 years of experience with men
she states she'll be her teacher and
both boys are amazed at her age kiluau
calls her an old hag and biscuit punches
him into the sky right after gom looks
at her his new men teacher she says that
they must obey and do whatever she says
however kilowell flatly rejects gon says
that they already have wing as their
teacher to which biscuit replies that
he's one of her students biscuit
explains to the boys that they will not
survive in the game alone until she
senses the presence of an enemy behind
her she stops immediately and tells them
to sit down and pretend they are
chatting they do when she explains that
there is an enemy behind her and tells
them her plan she will go to the south
while they go to the north when they
reach the tall pillar they should use
zetsu and rush back immediately after
that she slaps kiluah on the cheek
pretending they are fighting and goes
south while the boys go north seeing
that the enemy starts chasing biscuit as
gon and killua go back they find
biscuit's hair already cut by the enemy
and high behind the tall rocks they wash
his biscuit and the enemy fight see even
the enemy is defeated effortlessly by
her without using her nan much to gone
and killu as surprise
after they reunite they learn that
biscuit's main purpose for playing the
game is to find a jewel which can only
be found in greed island gonna ask sir
to postpone her treasure hunting and
teach them men
after reaching an agreement with the
boys she starts the training by
providing a certain rule for their enemy
whose name is revealed to be benolt he
must evade the boy's attacks within two
weeks if he is successful she will let
him escape but if he is knocked
unconscious or can't stand she will kill
him
also he is not allowed to leave the
crater the same rule applies for both
gon and kilua
with that said they begin the fight
while being old is trying to heal up
killua attacks him only to have his face
sliced by scissors gone tries to attack
him but is stopped by a scissors attack
as well
kiluah then tells gohan to keep an eye
on him while he attacks with rocks gohan
thinks it is a good idea and punches a
big rock behind him to make fallen
pieces he and killua then start
attacking benolt with many rocks sending
them towards him and making him struggle
to avoid them
as benolt avoids the rocks gone takes
his opportunity to land a kick on him
but to no avail as the boys finish
creating a forest of rocks they start
attacking the impeded bean old affected
by the attack tilua appears in front of
him and is about to punch when gone
suddenly stops him he says that it will
only be a waste if they stop the fight
now
and that they should continue it again
tomorrow after getting some rest they
keep fighting for days until binol
finally gives up on day 10. soon after
he leaves them biscuit says that they
should go by masadora they start their
43 miles journey to the town which will
take three hours once they get there
they head to the department store
biscuit buys three cards and then they
go back to the rocky area once they
arrive the cards which biscuit bought
are revealed to be tools for digging she
says that they should go back to
masadora in a straight line which means
they should dig through the big rocks to
make a path towards the town
gohan and killua dig until they've
reached the end of the rock
soon they both fall to the ground from
exhaustion however biscuit says that
they should sleep in a sitting position
she makes them both sit while holding a
rope which holds a rock above their head
kiluah finds this easy since he did this
type of training as an assassin algon
had his head hit by the rock soon after
falling asleep the next day they start
their training again by digging their
way to masadora they keep digging until
they find a solid rock that can't be
broken by going shovel suddenly gone has
an idea to use his aura and let it flow
to the shovel
kilua starts doing the same thing and
their digging becomes faster and
stronger biscuit states that they have
learned a new application of ten which
is shu she also states that once they
reach masadora they will have completed
the first stage
after digging through the rocks to
masadora for days gone and killua
finally reached the town
biscuit seems pleased by their work and
commands them to go back to the starting
point to which they reply with
complaints
on the way back she tells them that they
will now work on obtaining monster cards
she says that they both lack a plan of
attack while fighting and they will
learn to strategize biscuit tells them
to work on their defense she starts
releasing her aura and shows them her co
she explains what it is and will attack
with her fist but they must not dodge
she explains that in order to defend
themselves from co they must use co as
well on their entire body this technique
combines ten and ren which is called ken
biscuit tells gone to use wren and
defend himself from her punch
when both parties are ready with their
stance biscuit moves her fist towards
gone rather slowly which makes gone
relaxed however when biscuit's fist
meets gone's hand the impact is much
bigger than expected causing gon to fly
backwards several meters biscuit states
that it was only in the power of
co-alone and if gone had not used his
ken
his face would have been smashed she
will try again and reminds him to keep
using his can and try to withstand her
attack
gone is only able to use his co for two
minutes before he falls to the ground in
exhaustion biscuit says he must sustain
ken for at least 30 minutes or he won't
stand a chance
both gone and killua train their ken
until gone is finally able to use it for
30 minutes and withstand biscuits attack
later biscuit says they will learn
actual combat training she orders them
to use their ken as they do so she
explains in this state their attack and
defense power are both 50 and that they
should shift their fists to 70 and the
rest of 30th among them attack
she mentions they can use geo to alter
their power depending on the situation
which is called ryu
after demonstrating it she orders them
to do it finished with the training they
begin sparring they start the fight
slowly but it becomes faster in just two
weeks biscuit tells them that they will
begin training in individual categories
they start training in the enhancer
category she introduces level one which
is smashing rocks she tells them to
smash a thousand of them with a single
stone a day to clear the level however
gone quickly crumbles his own stone
followed by killua afterward biscuit
praises kilua's work and raises her
index finger both gon and kilua quickly
use their guild to find out what number
it is they both answer simultaneously
making the result a draw meanwhile
nick's alliance is gathered in a cave
with 133 cards 90 of them being the
restricted cards out of 100.
suddenly genther interrupts and he
reveals himself to everyone as the
bomber he then explains that he has
placed a bomb on all of them making
everyone panicked
gispa attempts to attack him from behind
but is seriously injured by a little
flower explosion which is placed on his
face by genthru he explains how to
disarm the bomb on their bodies they
have to touch him and say i caught the
bomber after that he shows the bombs
placed on their body an ability name
countdown he states he will trade their
lives for the 90 restricted slot cards
and that he will use an alternative
method if they agree
however they will die if they do nothing
when the timer reaches zero soon after
he leaves the game by using the leave
card
inside batterer's mansion genthru is
seen waiting with his other men in the
basement revealed to be sub and barra
pued appears alone surprising genthru
and thinking mix would come
when he requests puhat's ring put
refuses to give it to him and tries to
bargain with genthru however genthru
quickly grabs puet's neck choking him
and uses his little flower and ability
instantly killing him
the scene changes and shows 12 hours
before genthru reveals himself the
bomber a ship is seen sailing on the sea
ridden by phantom troop members shizuku
franklin schalnark finks featon and
cortopi
shalnar claims that they found greed
island in the real world